I'm a full-blown Austrian economist free
market person and have been for the past
34 years all of our children consider
themselves Democrats I myself am a
registered never told me yeah there's a
reason for that
the bowtie is kind of like the
Conservatives nose ring you know it's
probably not messed up enough for
Rothbard because he was like messy but
they should have a kind of a frazzled
prezzo look to it we see many more
younger people here this time that we
have seen in the past you probably
didn't know there were so many
libertarians over the age of 25 huh yeah
yeah big surprise the Tea Party is very
specific smaller government less taxes
get off my back so if it really doesn't
talk about that libertarianism to
conflicts just slightly with the Tea
Party there's a lot of conservative
Republicans here and we need to remind
them that Republicans are responsible
for as much big government growth as
Democrats are you breaking out of this
bubble since you've made it all the way
here to Las Vegas no the only other
thing I've done besides the conference
as a Cirque de Soleil if we could just
get the speakers in the unitards with
ostrovsky crystals it would dramatically
increase the attendance and the nice
thing about coming to freedom fest is
that you realize that there's a lot of
people that believe like you do so
you're not alone so you feel that Kerry
is like a bird that has rejoined the
flock here yes yes yes rivard when you
come here and you're surrounded by
people talking in reasonable tones
speaking from logic and intellect when
we go back I'll be there supporting him
to present from a less aggressive energy
at a more you know realistic productive
place